um hello everyone uh welcome to pi data
global 2021 uh i'm conrad one of the
co-chairs conference uh we're very happy
today to have uh vincente here with us
talking to us about uh introduction to
quantum computing with python
uh
qss
thanks
thank you very much conrad and thank you
everybody for your time
and
as kanda said like my name is vicente
and today i'm going to talk about
quantum computing python and how you can
connect both of them using kiskit
so within this talk i will be talking
what is quantum computing what are the
difference with classical computing and
i will go through some real world
applications right now then i will move
to the ibm quantum environment how to
use it how to get access and i will talk
a little bit about kiskit and then we
will go
together through a notebook and seeing
how to execute
one very simple experiment using quantum
computing
so first of all a little bit about me
and my name is vicente i've been 15
years working with data mainly with
anything that you can think of rational
databases nosql big data on premises on
the cloud and in my free time i like to
to play with other different
technologies and areas main the main
ones genomic cyber security and this one
that is quantum computing so feel free
after this talk to connect with me in
linting or in any other platform
if you are interested in talking about
data quantum computing
so first of all let's go about what is
quantum computing uh for those of you
that have heard about the term but i'm
not that familiar with it quantum
computing is based on quantum mechanics
and quantum mechanics is basically a
theory in physics
that describes the physical properties
of subatomic particles so what that
means that means that when you go into
the subatomic area particles behave in a
very interesting way so basically you
have particles that when you are not
observing them they behave as waves when
you are observing them they behave as
particles and they will collapse to a
specific value there are two main
properties that we are interested on and
i will explain later one of them is the
entanglement and basically what happens
when you are entangling
two particles is that
the value that one of them collapse the
other one will collapse to exactly the
same value
so one example i have two particles and
one i have it on my own the other one is
in australia for example in the other
part of the world so when the particle
that i have collapsed to one specific
value the one that is in australia will
collapse to exactly the same value
another of the interested
properties of quantum computing is the
superposition superposition is basically
that
one particle is gonna have any value
between zero and one i will go deeper
about this
in other slides but basically
everybody knows the schrodinger cat
example and this is what is based the
superposition
so if we go to a very simple comparison
between quantum computing and classical
computing
classic computing
work with bits and as you know bits are
one or zero that's it because we are
using superposition in quantum computing
a cubit like what could be a quantum bit
and may have any value between zero and
one and this is very important because
we are going to use this later and this
is what gives its performance and its
benefits to quantum computing
it allows you to store much more
information using quantum computing
that's classical computing meanwhile
with one bit you can store only one
state zero or one with one qe in quantum
computing you can store any value
between zero and one what you will have
is a probability of that specific qubit
being zero or being one
and again i will go later deeper about
this there are other principles that we
are very interested
in quantum computing and you have face
you have entanglement as i said before
you have interference but there is
something that you must keep in mind and
here are the challenges that we have
right now in quantum computing like all
of this sounds awesome it's more power
more storage
but there are some challenges one of
them is that quantum computing right now
is in its infants state what do i mean
with this right now if you want to code
in quantum computing you have to program
circuits
so you will have to use gates imagine
classical computing having to code
circuits using add or x4 gates in
quantum computing you will have to do
something like that
additionally uh right now the computers
don't have as many qubits as we would
want to if you read the news and that is
now like a new company that is
developing like personal computers for
quantum computing and i think that they
have five qubits so this is the states
in which we are now right now there are
only like five qubits
if you want to get a personal quantum
computer and finally that is the
probabilistic nature because when you
put your qubits in superposition any
value between 0 and 1 and what you have
is a probability of that qubit
being 0 or being 1 you can't run only
once your experiment you will need to
run it several times and get the most
common result
and again i will go deeper about this
later
so
one of the challenges as i was saying
before is that right now this is in its
infant's state it's not like i can buy a
quantum computer and i can get it into
my house what you have here on the left
is the famous google seeker more quantum
computer and you can see it's taking
like a huge room and on the right if we
want to compare with
the moment in which we had the classical
computing
at the same level
what you see on the right is the bomb
and is the machine that was used to
decode the enigma machine so this is
where we are right now with quantum
computing
so okay
it's very powerful there are some
challenges but
said that there are a lot of companies
governments
and areas in the industry in which they
are pushing a lot quantum computing and
this is because regardless of the
challenges that we have right now they
see a lot of benefits now and in the
short and long term so i will go through
some of the
real world applications that you could
use this
this is a very old
new from the newspaper i think that has
already like four or five years and this
is when china was testing quantum
entanglement for communications
so think on this when we were talking
before about entanglement when you have
two particles and you generate them
together and you put them in an
entangled state and you send one to one
part of the world and you send the other
to the other part of the world because
you know that when one of them is gonna
collapse to one specific value the other
one is gonna do it as well
is something that you should be able to
use for communications imagine very fast
communications and communication that
nobody can interfere so as you can see
here is something that some governments
are already testing
additionally there is a lot of
performance with some specific
algorithms
what that means
ensure that you have read some of the
news like people are trying to scare
like oh quantum computing is gonna break
our encryptions well right now we don't
have the power there are not enough
qubits for that to happen
but in the pace that we are progressing
there will be a moment in which quantum
computers will have enough qubits to be
able to break by brute force encryption
so as you can see it's an area in which
we want to keep our eyes on that we are
aware that there are some challenges but
there may be lots of benefits in
performance in the future
so now that you know a little bit more
about quantum computing
where is it right now what are the
challenges where is it going i can't
imagine that you said like okay
i unsolved i want to play with this i
want to start working with this i want
to get involved so there is a very
easy way to do any and that is using ibm
quantum environment
so because it's not that easy to get a
quantum computer you will have to get
used to it through a cloud providers
similar to what you do with aws
with a azure with other cloud providers
you will need to
use it through cloud vendors so how do
you do this um the easiest from my point
of view and obviously this is my point
of view is the ibm
quantum environment is free
it's easy to use you just need to create
your ibm id and you can start using it
it's going to provide to you two
different ways of working with quantum
computing one of them is going to be
through a ui
so you will be very visual working with
circuits and creating them and executing
and the other is using python and
keyskit with jupiter notebooks
so this is how it would look the visual
circuit creation in ibm
um as i said before it's very visual
something very interesting is that it
generates automatically code for you
based on the circuit
this code maybe open qsm or keyskit and
the openqsm is basically assembly code
the keyskit is the one that we are
interested that is available with python
so let me try to share
my
web browser
and we
ah
yes let me see if it works
happy days and this is what you should
be able to see
when you log in in the ibm quantum
environment so basically you would have
the quantum composer that is the one
that i was talking for visually creating
your circuits so if i launch it
if you are a very visual person what you
see here is a circuit you should be able
to add gates taking them out remember
what they said before the way in which
this word forkia is that
basically
you
need to work with circuits the way in
which we code is with circuits this is a
very visual way of doing it you can add
different gates and what you see here on
your right is this environment creating
the code for you you can create it in
assembly
or you can create it in kiskit
so when you start working with this when
you start playing it's going to be very
interesting to play around create your
circuits then see the different results
that you would get from there
so this is the visual part but if you
are more of a coding person like me let
me come back to my presentation
what we are interested is basically in
working with kiskid
so
there is that option as well using the
ibm quantum environment you have what
they call the ibm quantum lab and that
is basically
that is basically jupiter notebooks and
that is something that i want all of you
to be aware and is that
you don't need to use the ibm quantum
environment i am doing this because it's
easy for a presentation and it's going
to make my life way easier everything is
going to work perfectly i'm not going to
have any problem but you should be able
to use this on your local just
installing kiskit you can install it
with pip easy pc you install it you can
use it with your notebooks
but for this presentation i will use the
the quantum lab so once you have started
you will be able to use kiskit what is
kiski kiskit is a high-level code
language created by ibm and the idea is
to be able to code quantum experiments
using python it's open source is created
by ibm and is
the the standard in all the ibm
environments and is using even out of
the ibm environments
so if you log in there you should be
able to use it as any jupiter notebook
there are different notebooks that are
available for you the one that is the
more interesting is the getting started
is the one that they have been tuning a
little bit and is the one that we are
going to go through together later but
before we go together through the
notebook there are some basics that i
want you to be aware of so the first of
all i will go through the different
back-ends options that you have
then i will go through how to create a
basic circuit how to execute it and how
to check the results
so first of all
there are different ways in which you
can execute your quantum environments
you can execute it on the cloud using
for example ibm quantum environment and
what you will do is execute it in their
quantum machines that will be parts
packed they will be sent to a queue and
eventually it will be run in one of the
quantum computers that ibm has but the
easy part is that you should be able to
simulate it locally or in the ibm
quantum environment and in order to do
that what we use is kiskit ir that is
included in the kiskit libraries so one
that you install keyskit is available
for you and there are different
simulators see different backends the
most common is the state vector the
state vector basically what is going to
do when you execute your quantum
experiment is return to you a vector
with a states for your quantum
experiment you can use as well unitary
simulator basically what is going to
return for you is a matrix that is going
to represent your experiment and finally
you can use the same simulator so there
are different backends i we will execute
an experiment through all of them and i
will show you the differences but you
need to be aware that there are these
options for you the one that is the most
common is the state vector is the one
that i usually use when i do my
experiment as well you can run it in any
quantum computer
so let's say that we start creating our
base circuit well i what i have here in
these
snapshots is basically the same circuit
that i was showing to you in the visual
composer so what we are going to do is
recreate
that circuit using code using python and
using kisky key for you
import keyskit this is the library that
you're going to use as you can see it's
very easy to create a quantum circuit
with just three qubits you just need to
call quantum circuit the parameter is
three boom you have your circuit with
three qubits and then when you start
doing is because remember that we are
programming circuits what you will do is
start adding gates to different queue
bits
of your circuit here what we do is
adding a hadamard gate to the qubit zero
and then adding a couple of c not gates
so
easy to visualize your circuit
key skid works very well with matlab
lead so you you should be able to
basically using the draw function to
show how it's going to look your circuit
and now this is the interesting part you
have different backends and depending on
the back-end that you execute
your circuit you're going to have
different results what i am showing here
to you is how you simulate
in both back ends state vector and qsm
on the left what you see is how you
should execute this circuit in the state
vector on the right is what you see how
you would execute it in qsm it's very
similar at the end of the day basically
you are explaining to the code okay this
is the backend that i want to use on the
left we are using the state vector
simulator on the right we are using the
qsn simulator you execute it and you get
the results and then depending on the
way in which you want to see the results
there are different ways so
on the left if we have been using a
state vector and you want to check the
results what you're going to get as i
said before is a vector with the
different probabilities for each one of
the states so as you can see here we
were putting it in superposition in
entanglement sorry so you will have half
of the probability for zero zero
half of the probability for one one if
you want to visualize this this is how
you can do it again using math plot leaf
on the right is even easier and you
don't want to get any visualization
about the states you just want to see
the results so what you do is execute
the experiment
1000 times and then you get the counts
for the different results
remember because what i said before
about being a probabilistic nature
because once that you put your qubits
between zero and one in that state
what you're gonna get is a probability
this qubit can collapse to zero with a
probability of 50 percent can collapse
to one with a probability of 50 percent
so when you execute
this experiment
a number of times you will have what you
see on your right 50 percent of the
times more or less zero zero fifty
percent of the time more or less one one
again this is because the probabilistic
nature
of the
of the quantum computing
and now before going to the next steps i
have time so what we are gonna do is we
are gonna run it on our own
so if we go again here
we go to the lab as i was explaining
before let me launch my server it time
it out it's going to make me look bad
this is what happened with
the typical
papa
demos
okay let me launch my lap
and basically what i am launching here
is jupiter notebooks so we're gonna
you're gonna have different options in
the ibm
q experience basically you're gonna have
the option of running uh jupiter
notebooks different and different
versions but the one that we are
interested in getting started with kisky
this is the one that i have been
showcasing with the snapshot but we are
gonna run on our own so one that you
open this and this is available for all
of you
the easy part is basically to import
kiskit we do it no problem at all this
is how you create your circuit with
three qubits
it's basically creating your circuit
and this is where we are going to
recreate
the visual circuit that i was showing
you before we are adding a hadamard gate
we are adding different synod gates and
we want to visualize it so if we go to
visualize it
again this is how my circuit is going to
look now this is the interesting part
let's see how we execute it with
different backends that they have been
showing before and let's see what are
the results for each one
so first of them we can use the state
vector simulator this one remember what
i said before it's is gonna return to
you
a vector with the probabilities for each
different state of your circuit so
we decide we request this back-end
we run our circuit
we get the
result and then we want to see how it
looks
because we have our circuit in an
entangled position
both qubits are going to collapse always
to the same value
so what this means is that our result is
gonna be always zero zero zero
or one one one and this is because our
qubits are collapsing always to all
zeros or always to all ones because the
probabilistic nature what you have is an
estate in which 50 percent could
collapse to zero zero zero fifty percent
could collapse to one one one so this is
what you can see in this visual
representation here
if you
execute it in the unitary backend what
you will have is a matrix representing
the state of your circuit but the most
easy to follow the results is the open
qsm and i am going to show you why
we execute it in our open qsm backend
we execute it 1000 times because we are
interested in see the distribution of
our results and we get the counts what
you get with the counts is the number of
times that the results happened and the
number of times that there should happen
because we know that we are in an
entangled position
when we execute this and we get the
results we are going to get roughly
fifty percent of the times zero zero
zero fifty percent of the times one one
one
again because the probabilistic nature
if i execute this again the numbers are
gonna change slightly
and this is because you're not going to
get always exactly the same results as
you can see they change it a little bit
if i execute it again
let me go with it the counts will change
again but
always they are going to be roughly 50
and 50
and this is because me personally
encoded in this circuit
an entanglement in which i know that all
the qubits in that circuit are gonna
collapse always to zero zero zero or to
one one one
so okay let me come back to
the slides
and now that
you know what is quantum computing why
it's so interesting you are a little bit
more familiar with kiskid you should be
able to install it locally or to use the
ibm
queue experience
and you are able to go there and check
different notebooks that they have for
starters or you can even work with that
with your own ideas so what would be the
next steps let's say like you love this
and you say vicente i am only i love it
i want to play with this so my
recommendation for next steps is set up
your environment you don't really need
to use the ibm q experience environment
you should be able to install kiskit on
your local machine and be able to
execute it
and read some material i really really
really recommend this book i'm not
getting any fee for that but i do really
recommend it it's really good
programming quantum computer brings a
lot of examples a lot of different
algorithms that you can play with and i
do recommend it take a look and play
with channel algorithms and some of the
code samples that they provide
yes my final advice is to experiment
experiment experiment play around with
it right now i am a data person so i am
playing with different data processing
experiments they are a little bit
complex this is why not show it here
could take like a little bit of time to
explain the different algorithms and the
different things that i am trying but
you can do the same you can go in your
own laptop you can play around you can
install it
check it out this book get inspired by
feed by some of the tutorials that you
have in the ibm q experience uh
best of all if you have any doubt you
have any
problem any doubt about data about
phantom computing feel free to connect
with me in linting and i am happy to
talk about this this is one of my
passions
and i am happy to
to answer any question
in the slack channel or connect with me
offline through linting uh yeah come
back to me with any question any doubt
you may have
uh i want to thank you for all your time
and this is the end of my presentation
within time i let five minutes so thank
you very much everybody for your time
thank you vincente now stop the
recording deal
okay